STEPHANIE WONG: The
last day of Next is here
and it's all about
the community.
Community Day features sessions,
interactive experiences,
and demos for technical
practitioners, like yourself.
While the live broadcast will
highlight some of my favorite
sessions, you can find all
of the Community Day sessions
available on-demand
at g.co/cloud/next.
Keep in mind that you can
filter on the catalog page
by learning level, like
introductory, intermediate,
and advanced; track,
like AI and ML,
app dev, databases, or
infrastructure; job role,
like student, architect,
SRE, networking professional,
or security professional.
Now my recommendations for
the channel 1 broadcast
include a session
with Urs, our VP
of infrastructure, who will talk
through new developer-focused
announcements.
Don't miss this session, called
"Unleash the Innovators."
Then we're going to hop
into a spectacular DEI
session with one of the
founders of the internet,
"A conversation with Vint Cerf
and Jim Hogan on disability
in tech."
Next, go ahead and meet
the Women Techmakers team.
And then join the
learning and certification
Q&A with our experts.
And check out "Making
infrastructure invisible
for application
developers," where
you can discover how storage
can take care of failover
and disaster recovery with
automated data replication
and how networking can remove
the complexity of traffic
management as traffic grows.
"Building better partnerships
with open source communities"
will be a session
with the teams who
contributed to open source
projects this past year,
like Tensorflow,
Kubernetes, and Apache Beam,
and they even helped with
COVID-19 response efforts.
I also want to highlight
"Designing and building
serverless solutions," which
will feature my teammates,
developer advocates
for a group discussion
on Cloud Run, Cloud
Functions, and App Engine.
So you are going to learn
what workloads are best suited
for serverless and
some tips and tricks.
Channel 2 of the broadcast
will cover sessions
on ML and Google
Developer Community
gatherings for both
North America and APAC.
And channel 3 is all
about hands-on labs
for GKE Autopilot, ETL
processing with Dataflow,
Vertex AI, and security.
So I hope you enjoy our
final day three of Next.
And remember, connect on
social with the hashtag
#GoogleCloudNext, and reach
out to me @stephr_wong.